das ist ein bisschen ein hahnenkampf
unter den ministerpräsidenten so klar
muss man das glaube ich sagen da will
jeder noch mal glänzen jeder will in den
medien sein jeder wird derjenige sein wo
am ende vielleicht gesagt wird mensch
der hat es doch schon vorher gesagt und
das haben wir in den vergangenen monaten
erlebt dadurch dass es eben diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
ist es aber am ende trotzdem so dass
dann vor allem diese große
pressekonferenz mit kanzlerin merkel und
dem vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt ist
es kälter und dem stellvertreter markus
söder ins medien blickfeld kommt also
dass alle sozusagen diese drei personen
dann in den medien sehen bei uns und auf
den fernsehsendern in den zeitungen und
so weiter und ist es sozusagen wichtig
für armin laschet in nrw aber natürlich
auch vor dem hintergrund seiner
ambitionen jetzt als möglicher cdu-chef
und dann kanzlerkandidat klar zu machen
dass eine eigene position hat und diese
position durchsetzen will und man darf
ja nicht vergessen
nrw ist das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland 16 millionen menschen leben
dort und natürlich spricht an
ministerpräsident zuallererst zu ihnen
bei armin laschet geht es aber wie
gesagt auch darum ein zeichen zu setzen
was er denn tun würde wenn er
kanzlerkandidat und möglicherweise den
kanzler wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren